[Musica]
cos'è la ricerca la ricerca la scienza
multidisciplinare che copre vari ambiti
io mi occupo di ricerca scientifica e in
particolare di ricerca biomedica la
ricerca scientifica viene svolta da
scienziati da ricercatori che lavorano
in laboratorio da sperimentatori la
ricerca un lavoro creativo che ci
permette di costruire nuove conoscenze
attraverso lo studio dettagliato e
rigoroso di determinate problematiche
possiamo distinguere due tipi di ricerca
il primo è detto ricerca di base o anche
fondamentali già il suo nome indica come
questa ricerca sia necessario
indispensabile per aumentare le nostre
conoscenze questa ricerca viene anche
definita slow science perché per
condurla in modo adeguato ha curato sono
necessari anni e anni di studio di
lavoro e non ha una ricaduta pratica
immediata
il secondo tipo di ricerca viene
definito invece traslazionale o ricerca
applicata altro non è che l'applicazione
della ricerca di base
questa ricerca viene chiamata a fast
science perché deve essere veloce perché
deve cercare di concretizzare il più
velocemente possibile le scoperte della
ricerca di base ma tornando a me vi ho
detto che mi occupo di ricerca perché ho
scelto di diventare ricercatrice
all'epoca dei miei studi ho scelto di
fare questo lavoro
spinta da un'idea abbastanza ambiziosa
dall'idea di voler curare i tumori di
trovare una via per poterlo fare
ho deciso quindi di buttarmi a capofitto
nella scienza e nello studio della
medicina per raggiungere quelle
conoscenze che mi avrebbero permesso poi
in seguito di rispondere a delle mie
domande nella scienza e nella ricerca
per rispondere a dei quesiti è
necessario seguire tutta una serie di
procedure sperimentali che definiscono
il metodo scientifico
quindi il metodo scientifico non è altro
che un processo sperimentale che noi
ricercatori
dobbiamo sempre seguire quando facciamo
ricerca quando ha intrapreso
questa strada alcune delle domande che
mi sono fatta sono state cercare di
capire cosa la cellula tumorale aveva di
diverso rispetto alle cellule normali
quali ingranaggi erano rotti quali
meccanismi alterati che rendevano la
cellula tumorale capace di dividersi in
modo incontrollato per dare origine a un
tumore
quindi da brava ricercatrice ho seguito
il metodo scientifico per cercare di
rispondere a questioni e domande ho
iniziato quindi a guardare le cellule
tumorali a guardare dentro le cellule
tumorali e in particolare a strutture
chiamato i mitocondri i mitocondri sono
la centrale energetica delle nostre
cellule
quindi sono le strutture che forniscono
il carburante alle cellule per far sì
che queste possono rimanere vitali io ho
ipotizzato che i mitocondri potessero
essere qui gli ingranaggi che si rompono
all'interno delle cellule tumorali
ho quindi deciso di validare le mie
ipotesi e testarli in laboratorio
sperimentando e ottenendo dei risultati
i risultati che ho ottenuto hanno
dimostrato come effettivamente i
mitocondri delle cellule tumorali
spesso sono diversi funzionano male ho
capito che mitocondri sono proprio
quegli ingranaggi che si rompano nelle
cellule tumorali e ho capito anche come
aggiustare questi ingranaggi per far sì
che le cellule tumorali riescano a
tornare a funzionare come una cellula
normale ma se oggi sono qui a
raccontarvi seppur brevemente alcune
delle mie ricerche è perché ho avuto la
possibilità di fare ricerca è perché ho
avuto la possibilità di applicare il
metodo scientifico e di rispondere alle
mie domande
ma come e dove si fa ricerca di sicuro
per condurre questo tipo di ricerche
sperimentali non bisogna utilizzare
laboratori improvvisati o non si possono
fare nel garage di casa
per fare questo tipo di ricerca
sperimentale seguendo un metodo
scientifico
c'è bisogno di trovare laboratori
strutturati laboratori accreditati non
solo una volta trovati i laboratori per
fare ricerca è necessario avere anche
delle strumentazioni dedicate non solo
per fare ricerche io ho bisogno anche di
reagenti non solo
per fare ricerca un ricercatore ha
bisogno di costruire un team un team che
lavora con lui è vero che questa fase
non è così fondamentale un ricercatore
potrebbe fare anche da solo però è ovvio
che lavorando insieme lavorando in un
team si arriva prima ottenere un
risultato quindi concludendo se un
giovane ricercatore volesse
intraprendere questa strada della
ricerca dove trova un laboratorio
strutturato idoneo per fare ricerca
oggi in italia i luoghi d'eccellenza ed
elezione dove poter fare ricerca libera
quindi la ricerca decisa dallo
sperimentatore stesso sono le università
entrare all'università è tutt'altro che
facile
e quando dico entrare intendo cercare un
luogo uno spazio dove fare ricerca
all'università non funziona purtroppo
che ricercatore bussa alla porta del
rettore dicendo di avere delle idee
buone e chiedendo di poterle
sperimentare chiedendo di avere degli
spazi non funziona così un ricercatore
per prima cosa deve cercare di vincere
delle borse di studio ed entrare a far
parte di un team di un ricercatore già
strutturato nel frattempo deve cercare
di dimostrare quanto vale e di
dimostrare che ha delle idee valide e
quindi di convincere la propria
istituzione a dargli degli spazi ecco
questo è difficilissimo io ne sono un
esempio io tuttora non ho degli spazi
miei esclusivi dove fare la mia ricerca
la mia fortuna è stata che il mio
mentore dove anni fa vinsi le mie prime
borse di studio che mi hanno fatto
approcciare a questo mondo ha creduto in
me e mi ha permesso di usare i suoi
spazi come se fossero i miei per fare la
mia ricerca
ma ammesso che quindi un ricercatore
difficilissimo ma riesce a trovare degli
spazi all'università per fare ricerca
come dove trova reagenti strumenti e
come mette insieme un team che serve per
lavorare con lui
ecco tutto questo è a carico del
ricercatore stesso quindi un ricercatore
che ha voglia di fare questo lavoro deve
trovare i fondi per pagare non solo il
proprio stipendio ma per pagare anche i
reagenti per pagarsi gli strumenti e per
pagare lo stipendio dei collaboratori
che devono lavorare con lui
giusto per darvi un'idea di numeri
progetti sperimentali come quelli che
sto conducendo io costano circa dai 100
e 150 mila euro all'anno per pagare un
team di 12 persone con uno stipendio
medio di 1.200 euro al mese
dove può un giovane trovare tutti questi
soldi
ogni anno l'unica via che ha è quella di
cercare di concretizzare le proprie idee
le proprie ipotesi in un progetto
scritto quindi un ricercatore per prima
cosa deve scrivere un progetto in cui
deve dettagliare il le ricerche che
vuole fare le metodologie che vuole
utilizzare il budget che gli serve bene
scrivere una sorta di vero e proprio
business plan scientifico questo
progetto poi viene sottomesso degli enti
finanziatori che possono essere pubblici
o privati nazionali o internazionali e
viene valutato da esperti scienziati del
settore
solamente il 5 10 per cento di tutti i
progetti presentati viene finanziato
quindi solamente il 5 10 per cento di
ricercatori riesci a ottenere i soldi
per poter fare la propria ricerca
io di questi progetti ne ho scritti
molti e con un po di fortuna perché
quella serve sempre sono riuscito a
ottenere soldi che mi permettessero di
allestire il mio laboratorio quindi di
comprare strumenti reagenti e di
allestire un team di ricerca una volta
fatto tutto questo quindi una volta
trovati spazi e soldi allora il
ricercatore può iniziare a fare
effettivamente la ricerca in laboratorio
e poi finito il piano sperimentale
quindi finiti gli esperimenti la ricerca
finisce no inizia una fase altrettanto
faticosa una fase che serve per avere il
riconoscimento di qualità delle proprie
ricerche dei propri risultati
è quel processo che noi scienziati
chiamiamo di peer review quindi un
ricercatore devo organizzare i propri
risultati in un articolo scientifico
quindi deve per tagliare le ricerche che
ha fatto i risultati che ho ottenuto le
metodologie causato è di nuovo questo
articolo deve essere valutato da un team
di esperti internazionali
solo quando questo team di esperti
valuta che il nostro operato i nostri
risultati le nostre
scoperte sono sufficientemente valide
apporta una sorta di sigillo di qualità
alle nostre scoperte e queste possono
venire pubblicate sulle riviste
scientifiche e quindi diffuse a tutta la
comunità anche non scientifica giusto
per riassumere quindi il processo di una
sperimentazione di base dall'idea di un
ricercatore fino a tagliare il traguardo
quindi fino a vedere le proprie ricerche
pubblicate dura almeno in media sette
anni e poi tagliato il traguardo quindi
è finita la scienza no la scienza non
finisce mai
ogni giorno noi continuiamo a fare
scienza perché come dice il nome ricerca
significa cercare ricercare ancora
guardare anche dove altri hanno già
guardato e cercare di cogliere gli
aspetti che gli altri non hanno colto
ogni scoperta fatta ogni scoperta che
viene pubblicata e divulgata non è altro
che un piccolo pezzo di puzzle che tutti
noi ricercatori nel mondo stiamo cercare
stiamo cercando di comporre per arrivare
più velocemente possibile a rispondere a
dei quesiti
io questo percorso questo traguardo lo
ha tagliato più volte ad oggi ho il mio
attivo più di 100 articoli su riviste
scientifiche
ho ricevuto numerosi premi numerosi
riconoscimenti e ne sono molto
orgogliosa perché ha permesso di far
conoscere la comunità anche non
scientifica le ricerche le scoperte che
ho fatte che sto facendo ma da un punto
di vista pratico il fatto di aver fatto
tutte queste scoperte di aver pubblicato
tutti questi articoli cosa mi ha dato è
vero ho fatto carriera all'interno
dell'università nel 2019 quindi non
tanto tempo fa sono riuscito ad ottenere
il posto fisso
quel famoso posto fisso tanto nominato
anche da checco zalone e quindi cosa
vuol dire si vuol dire che io dal 2019
non devo auto finanziarmi lo stipendio e
poi quindi vuol dire che adesso io ho
finito di fare ricerca teoricamente sì
praticamente però no perché la ricerca
di base non può e non deve fermarsi
anche dopo l'acquisizione di un posto
fisso
io tutti i giorni continua a darmi da
fare con nuove idee e cercare nuovi
fondi scrivere
di progetti per dare una mano anche i
giovani ricercatori di crescere però è
vero
a un certo punto mi sono chiesta se era
questo quello che volevo quando ho
scelto di diventare ricercatrice sera
questo se quello che volevo era
continuare a pubblicare ea fare scoperte
nuove quindi aumentare le nostre
conoscenze e mi son dato una risposta è
questa risposta è stata no io in realtà
quando ho scelto di fare la ricercatrice
volevo fare qualcosa di più non volevo
solo studiare i tumori e aumentare le
nostre conoscenze sui tumori io volevo
fare qualcosa di più pratico volevo
arrivare a curare i tumori
quindi ho deciso che dovevo cambiare
dovevo cambiare il mio approccio alla
scienza alla ricerca
dovevo cercare di fare qualcosa di più
concreto e quindi cercare di trasferire
applicare le mie scoperte ai nostri
pazienti
nel mio caso quindi intraprendere anche
la via della ricerca traslazionale ma se
come vi ho detto fare ricerca di base è
difficile fare ricerca traslazionale
applicata lo è ancora di più per darvi
di nuovo un idea di numeri di tutte le
scoperte e le pubblicazioni che noi
ricercatori facciamo in tutto il mondo
in un anno che sono circa un paio di
milioni solo qualche decina di queste
riesce a trovare un'applicabilità riesce
a concretizzarsi valle della morte così
noi chiamiamo ricercatori chiamiamo dove
finiscono e muoiono tutte le ricerche le
nuove conoscenze che facciamo le nuove
scoperte la valle della morte è quel è
quella quella dimensione quel gap che
separa i nostri laboratori
quindi la ricerca di base alla clinica
ai pazienti ma perché si crea questa
valle della morte perché la ricerca di
base non riesce a concretizzarsi non
riesce ad essere applicata
io parlo per la mia esperienza quindi
per il mio campo di ricerca in campo
medico oncologico ed essenziale
essenzialmente le motivazioni sono due
una legata ai fondi e la seconda legate
ricercatori stessi
per quanto riguarda i fondi gli ho detto
che già per la ricerca di base solo il 5
massimo 10 per cento dei ricercatori
riesce a trovare i fondi per fare la
propria ricerca ecco nel caso della
ricerca traslazionale applicata gli enti
finanziatori e i fondi sono ancora meno
quindi capite bene la difficoltà di
portare avanti questo tipo di ricerca
per quanto riguarda i ricercatori stessi
già il percorso della ricerca di base
che un ricercatore deve affrontare prima
di far ricerca traslazionale è un
percorso duro tanti ricercatori non
riescono nemmeno a tagliare una volta al
traguardo e quindi spesso non sono
spinti da questa voglia di fare qualcosa
di più di far qualcosa di diverso e se
non è ricercatore stesso che cerca di
applicare le proprie scoperte difficile
che qualche altro ricercatore lo faccia
per lui ho deciso quindi che dovevo fare
qualcosa di diverso
dovevi intraprendere una nuova sfida
dovevo impedire che tutte le mie
scoperte e le mie ricerche finissero in
questa valle della morte
dovevo cercare di creare un collegamento
tra il mio laboratorio le mie scoperte
di ferrara al nostro territorio quindi
al nostro ospedale nostro paziente di
ferrara creare una sorta di ponte di
collegamento è nato quindi a rose un
progetto ambizioso un progetto di
ricerca traslazionale in campo in colò
gico per il nostro territorio a rose
nasce dall'idea non solo mia ma da altri
tre colleghi altri tre colleghi un
ricercatore due colleghi clinici a rose
nasce con la voglia l'idea di creare una
piattaforma traslazionale che colleghi
fisicamente praticamente i nostri
laboratori sul nostro territorio al i
nostri ospedali ai nostri pazienti
quindi gli obiettivi principali di a
rose sono quelli di accelerare il
trasferimento delle nostre scoperte ai
pazienti e di aumentare il numero di
scoperte che possono generare nuovi
trattamenti per i nostri pazienti
oggi a rose non è solo un progetto o è
già iniziato a costruire questo ponte
per collegare i nostri laboratori ai
nostri ospedali
ho già iniziato a gettare le basi per
fare questa piattaforma traslazionale
cosa mi manca il percorso è ancora lungo
purtroppo come per la ricerca di base
anche per la ricerca
geniale c'è la necessità di scrivere
progetti noi questo l'abbiamo già fatto
e questi progetti devono essere
approvati da un comitato etico fatto
stiamo già iniziando ad analizzare
campioni dei nostri pazienti per cercare
di trovare cure personalizzate
ora però come per la ricerca di base ci
servono fondi e harold deve trovare
questi fondi per completare questo
progetto
per farlo però c'è bisogno di creare un
grande team
quindi non solo noi quattro che abbiamo
ideato questo progetto ma abbiamo
bisogno che in questo team siano
presenti anche tutti i medici e il
personale sanitario del nostro
territorio non solo tutta la società
civile quindi anche tutte le persone al
di fuori della scienza e tutta
l'imprenditoria sono messi insieme
quindi col supporto di tutto il
territorio
penso che potremo fare qualcosa di
grande e a ferrara per ferrara con
l'auspicio per me di ottenere il premio
più ambito quello di essere riuscita a
curare o di aver aiutato a curare
qualcuno dei nostri pazienti
grazie
[Applauso]